associer le gouvernement du québec au
suprématie ce meuble en bois ceci un
journaliste d'être d'une manière ou
d'une autre à copiner avec l'extrême
droite c'est pas acceptable
c'était le 30 mars dernier gabriel
nadeau-dubois réagissait à cette
publication du collectif antiraciste des
colonials c'est la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase
il ya présentement oui une motion de
blâme sur les façons de faire de ce
collectif lors le groupe arts appliqués
par une mise en demeure accusant le
parti de mener une campagne de
diffamation lorsqu'on cherche un
électorat lorsqu'on veut peut-être aller
chercher une frange plus nationalistes
donc c'est très populaire aujourd'hui de
taper sur des mouvements antiracistes
eve torres et alisha tki apic sont fous
porte-parole du collectif anti raciste
et colonial qui selon leurs estimations
regroupant environ 80 membres sur les
vingt mille militants en règle de québec
solidaire
l'une porte le voile l'autre et inuit
elles étaient toutes deux candidates
lors de la dernière élection
elle affirme aujourd'hui que le parti
fait preuve de racisme systémique
[Musique]
alisha donne l'exemple de sa candidature
en 2018 qui n'était selon elle qu'une
façon pour le parti de sauver la face
puisqu'elle s'est rapidement senti mise
de côté après l'élection
faire la paix dans le parti semble
difficile et s'inquiète pierre mouterde
un des membres fondateurs de québec
solidaire
le fait de rester à des questions
sensationnaliste à des invectives
personnelles plutôt que d'aider que ce
débat puisse aider à la construction de
québec solidaire à son renforcement
que ces débats risquent au contraire de
l'amener à s'effriter un petit peu plus
puisqu'on voit c'est le défi d'un parti
qui sanctionna lit c'est à dire qu'il
veut aussi élargir sa base électorale et
ça des fois ça peut déplaire à sa barre
des tensions presque inévitable selon le
politologue
eric montigny il n'est pas étonné de
voir des groupes de gauche radicale
faire leur niche à québec solidaire ça
se voulait être parapluie de tous les
groupes de gauche au québec et c'est
l'objectif
même la fondation québec c'est donc
c'est normal de voir ce type de courant
émerger à l'intérieur de québec
solidaire c'est normal que à gauche
comme à droite
un billet gauche comme dans la nouvelle
gauche y ait des gens qu'on sait qu'on
pourrait avoir des certaines critiques
par rapport à leurs pratiques
philippe maymil nombre et est un
militant antiraciste
il n'est membre d'aucun parti mais il
comprend qu'au delà des coups d'éclat le
combat de la gauche radicale créer un
inconfort dans le débat public
si on atteint une certaine égalité il ya
un groupe qui perd au change c'est
certain ce fric nécessairement il me
semble que ça fait pas puis c'est normal
que ça fasse pas c'est vécu comme une
violence
à québec solidaire l'impasse persiste
lise sont prêts à aller jusqu'au bout
les révolutions peuvent pas toujours
tranquille
les autres croient que le débat peut
encore s'apaiser
et c'est valérie gamache phrase au
canada québec
[Musique]